I have to start again. We have to pick up in volume 10, January 28, 1911, and most of
the messages we will be dealing with in this session are about love. I've told you a number
of times that the summary of the 36 volumes is divine will and love. Okay, same person
we're dealing with. Okay, so I'll give you a whole lot of references to love and then
I won't give you any. Is that okay? Because there's only a certain amount and that's it.
One Corinthians 13 verses 1 to 13. One Corinthians 14 verse 1, which says you must want love
more than anything else. And I'll give you John 13, 34 to 35. And in the next one, I'll
give you another dose. Is that okay? Yeah. So the heading for this is that love forces
God to tear the veils of faith. As I was in my usual state, Louisa said, the head, the
heart of my sweet Jesus made itself seen. And as I looked inside of Jesus, I could see
his heart in him. And then looking inside of myself, I could see his most holy heart
also within me. So there's your John 14 20 to 21, you in me and I in you both completely
one. Oh, how much gentleness, how many delights, how many harmonies could be felt in that heart,
Louisa said. Then while I was delighting with Jesus, I heard his most gentle voice coming
out from his heart telling me daughter, delight in my heart. Love wants its outpourings. Otherwise,
who could go on, especially one who really loves me and does not admit within herself
any other pleasure, any other taste. Now, the book says taste, I think should put the
word satisfaction, any other satisfaction, or any other love. Now, the book says life
but love, any other love. So what Jesus is saying here is that especially for people
who really love him. Now, that's your Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10. Hero Israel, the Lord your God
is one Lord and you shall love the Lord your God with all your heart, all your soul, all
your mind, and all your being. Now, it's the word all that's terribly important. Okay.
And that's why he said that especially for people who really love God, and therefore
they don't have other pleasures. They're not looking for something outside of him. They're
not looking for any other satisfactions beside God. You remember Teresa of Evella, God alone,
suffice it. Okay. And they're not looking for any other love. They're not looking for anything
outside of love. So Louisa said, I felt so drawn towards them that love itself. Now, notice
the capitals. That's that's divine love forces me to tear the veils of faith. And I reveal
myself. Now, Jesus is saying that if you want to really see him, all you've got to do is
love more and more and more deeply and more completely because he is love and the faith
that tells you he is love. Gradually, the veil will be drawn back and you will be able
to see. Now, whether that seeing is with your eyes or with your interior soul, it's up to
him. Most of us get it in the interior. Okay. So I feel so drawn to people who love in this
way, that love itself forces me to tear the veils of faith. And I reveal myself, making
them enjoy down here also. That means down on earth, paradise at intervals. Now, that
is Sam. I think it is 39. You'd never think I prepared this, would you? And I think it's
nine to 10 that you drink from the torrents of his delight. Okay. But he said, I anticipate
heaven also in this life. Now, many of the saints have acknowledged that that they experienced
heaven on earth. Enjoy, he said, feel my delights. See how many contentments there are. Notice
the S, contentments there are in my heart. Take part in everything, pour yourself out
in my love so that yours may expand more and you may love me more. Now, there's no limit
to love. Love is eternal. And so heaven is a continuous expansion in love. And therefore,
the ecstasy of happiness in heaven increases, increases, increases what we would say with
time. Of course, it's outside of time. Okay. Now, notice he says that in order to grow in
love, we must actually love. Hence the acts of love that we make, you know, that I love
you with your own love in your divine will. Okay. And so if you love him with his own love,
and the more often you repeat that, the better. And if you haven't got time to repeat it all
day, just say, Lord, I want to multiply this to infinity, to cover everything, not to imply
apply it to infinity. So in the next paragraph, while Jesus was saying this, Louisa said,
I saw some priests. And Jesus continued, my daughter, the church in these times is agonizing,
but it won't die. Why is it agonizing? This is 1911. You have the infiltration of communism
and Marxism and rationalism and modernism and all the other isms. Okay. She will rise
again, even more beautiful. The good priests strive for a life more stripped and more stripped
means that they're detached from the things of the earth, more sacrificed, so more self-giving,
more pure. Okay. So that's in body, mind and spirit. The bad priests strive for a life more
interested, more comfortable and more sensual, all earthly. Well, that goes without saying
that one is just the contrast of the other. And Jesus said, I speak, but not to them,
not to the bad ones. Why would he not speak to the bad ones? Because they wouldn't hear
and they wouldn't be interested in what he would want to say if he's talking about the
cross and self sacrifice and so on. I speak to the few good ones, be they even one per
town. Wow. Considering this is a century ago, it's much worse now, isn't it? To these,
that's the good priests, I speak and I command and I beg and I supplicate that they may make
these houses of reunion. Now, it came to me, we've had a lot about these houses of reunion.
It came to me that a more correct way of using that terminology that we would understand
is a retreat house. Then you will understand it. Okay. Because I've been saying to the
Lord for ages, houses of reunion don't say anything to us that he said retreat houses
to. And it's just that language changes. Okay. So we've had lots of retreat houses set
up since then all over the place. So I beg them to make these retreat houses. Okay. Saving
me the priests who will come into these shelters by rendering them completely free from the
bonds of the family. Now that's specific to Italy. The bonds of the family mean running
the family business and so on. And through these few good ones, my church will recover
from her agony. These are my support, my pillars. We even use that language, the pillars of
the church. Don't dream. The church has two sets of pillars. One set are the priests and
the other set are the families. They're the two pillars of the church. And so these are
my support, my pillars, the continuation of the life of the church. I do not speak to
the others. That is to those who do not feel like freeing themselves in the bond of the
family. In other words, they want to stay in their captivity. They want to stay in their
sinfulness. So what's the point in wasting words? Because if I speak, I'm certainly not
listened to even more at the mere thought of breaking every bond. They become indignant.
Okay. Listen to this. This is going to be very frightening. Unfortunately, they are
accustomed to drinking the cup of vested interest is what we would say. You'd have to
put the word vested interest and the like. That's all the worldliness that goes with
it. And while being sweetness for the flesh, it is poisoned for the soul. Okay. These will
end up drinking the sewer of the world. Now the sewer of the world is hell. What you pour
into a sewer is what are the dregs of human life. It's not very frightening. I want to
save them at any cost, but I'm not listened to. Therefore, I speak, but for them, it is
as if I weren't speaking. Now, this is true. And we know this in our own lives that the
Lord has spoken to the church through many apparitions of our blessed lady, through many
apparitions of Sacred Heart, through Sister Faustina, through Padre Pio, and you could
go on and on. But who listens? Only a very small group actually listens. It's very frightening,
really. You know, it must be awful from his point of view. So there's a short message
about priests on February the 4th, 1911. And it's about these retreat houses. So continuing
in my usual state, blessed Jesus said, my daughter, tell Father G to solicit the retreat
houses. I'm going to use our language now. Is that okay? Let them not, let them not make
the persecution come earlier, woe to them. Now a persecution coming to the church. And
in other words, God would permit it for our chastisement if there's real disobedience
to his will. In fact, where these retreat houses will be established, either the persecutions
will be milder or wounds will be spared. The rot is great and it is too stinking. And
it takes iron and fire by necessity. Iron is for cutting the gangrenous flesh and fire
for purifying. Now that happened in World War One. But in World War One, two particular
houses that were set up by Mactimilian Colby in Hiroshima that they were spared when the
atomic bombs came down and they had absolutely no danger. And a house of Jesuit priests who
were saying the Rosary every day, they were spared completely as well. So that's what
he's saying that, you know, if we would only respond to the challenge that he's giving
to us, he would spare us in time of persecution. Okay. So February the 8th, 1911, we come back
to the subject of love. And I want to give you the rest of the references on love. And
then that's it. Okay. Ephesians three, 16 to 21. And John 19, sorry, John 59. Okay.
So continue in my usual state. I spent about six days all immersed in the love of my blessed
Jesus. Now in the last message, Jesus told her to pour out her love. That's the way to
grow. Okay. And so this is what she's saying. She spent almost a week just in the love of
Jesus. Can you imagine? To the point that at times I felt I could take no more and I
would say to him enough enough, I can't take anymore. And that means that if a jug is full,
it can't take anymore. You can have an ocean of liquids, but the jug can't take it. I felt
as if I was in a bath of love, she said, that penetrated deep into the marrow of my bones.
Jesus would speak to me of love and of how much he loved me. And I would speak of love
to him. You don't know how anybody would have the guts to speak of love to him. But anyway,
he is love. And you can't tell him anything. He isn't. The beautiful thing is that sometimes
Jesus would not let himself be seen. And I, swimming in this bath of love, would feel
the circle of my poor nature crack. Now what she's saying is the desire to go to heaven
is unbearable. Because that's what love actually does. It wants to break this bond. And I would
lament to him and he would whisper in my ear, I am love, I am love. If you feel love, it
is sure that I am with you. Okay. So that's one John four, seven to 17. So what he's saying
is in the depths of your being, if you are aware that you are loved by God, that is the
sign that he is with you. And you need to take that as a sign of discernment, because we are
aware of it, aren't we? Otherwise, you wouldn't be in such good humor. Other times, Louisa
said, I would lament, and he would say in my ear, Louisa, you are my paradise on earth
and your love renders me happy is not absolutely fantastic. So he says that Louisa's love renders
him happy on earth. Okay. Because she's the only one who loves him to this extent. Okay.
Just love him at different levels. So Louisa said, Jesus, my love, what are you saying?
Do you want to make fun of me? You are already happy because of yourself. Why do you say
that you're happy because of me? And it's wonderful that she asks these questions because
it's we who need the answer. So Jesus said, listen to me very carefully, my daughter,
and you will understand what I'm telling you. There is no created thing that does not receive
life from my heart. So that's John 1 verses 1 to 5. It's also Colossians chapter 1.
And it's John 14, 6. I am the way, the truth and the life. So he says, there's not one
created thing that doesn't receive life from me. Now, as we go on, he's going to explain
very clearly that the divine will is in everything that God has made. The divine will is in the
sun or it wouldn't exist. The divine will is in the plants or they wouldn't exist. The
divine will is in you and me or we wouldn't exist. If the divine will removes itself,
we disintegrate, we go back into nothingness. So there's nothing that doesn't receive life
from him. All souls, I'm putting souls instead of creatures, are like many cards that come
from my heart and have life from me. By necessity and naturally, everything they do is all reflected
in my heart. That requires a little bit of thought. That means everything we do, every
thought, every word, every action, every motivation, everything is reflected in him because he
is the source of our life. Be it even one little movement. Isn't that something? As a consequence,
if they do evil, if they do not love me, they give me continuous bother. That chord resounds
in my heart with the sounds of displeasure, of bitterness, of sin, and it forms in it such
lugubrious sounds as to render me unhappy on the part of that chord. That's like saying,
you have a wonderful harp, but there's one chord that is out of tune and it spoils everything,
doesn't it? This discordant note. On the other hand, if it loves me, it is all intent on contenting
me and that chord gives me continuous pleasure. Now you have your harp with all the chords, right?
And it forms festival sweet sounds which harmonize with my whole life. And on the part of that chord,
I enjoy so much as to be rendered happy and to enjoy my own paradise because of it. Now the harp
is his, the chords are his, but he still enjoys the music that comes from it. If you understand this
well, you will no longer say that I make fun of you. Okay. Now, Louisa very seldom goes into an
ecstasy of love and tells you what is in her, going on inside of her, but we have this is coming up
right now and it's very unusual for her. For St. Therese of Lissue, it was normal, she was very
artistic and very musical in herself and needed to express herself this way. For John of the
Cross, he expressed himself so incredibly in poetry that his poetry is still studied in the
universities because of his magnificent structure and expression and everything else, even with
people who don't actually have the union with God that John had. So this eulogy to love is just,
you're going to get about two of them, I think. And then Louisa won't give you any more because
it's not like her. She's, she's very private. And so in the next paragraph then, Louisa said,
"And here's what I would say about love and what Jesus would say." So we're going to get a dialogue
here. And this dialogue is like the bride and the bride groom in the song of songs, delighting in
each other. Okay. I'll say it with some nonsense and maybe disconnected because the mind does not
adapt itself completely to words. So in other words, it's not natural for Louisa to talk like this.
So write Louisa before stanza one. Okay. And before we talk at all, the heading I have for myself is
it's all about love. And if you don't learn your love, sonata, on earth, you'll have to learn it in
heaven. Okay. Song of songs to for his banner over me is love. Okay, his banner over me is love.
"Oh my Jesus, you are love." I have to try and put this into English. Is that okay? Because
with the translation, you get the nouns and the adverbs in the wrong places. "Oh my Jesus, you are
love. You are all love. I want you alone. I desire you alone. I desire and long for love.
I supplicate love and I implore love of you." Now, I would imagine in the original Italian that would
all rhyme, you know. "Love invites me," she says. "Love is my life." That's Song of Songs 5-2. "Love
kidnaps my heart." I think that's fantastic. "Deep into the womb of my Lord. With love,
he enabriates me. With love, he delights me. I all alone and only for you. You alone and only for me."
Now, notice, you see, this is spousal love. It's completely
personal and it is also, I'm looking for a word now. The word won't come to me.
It absolutely excludes anybody else. It's exclusive love. I got it in the end. It's exclusive love.
It's him for me only and I'm for him only. Is that okay? So, "I all alone and only for you and
you alone only for me." It's this exclusive spousal love. "Now that we are alone, shall we speak about
love? Oh, please, let me understand how much you love me because only in your love can one
understand love." Okay. Now, his love is always given with a capital L and her love is given with
a small L. Have you noticed that? That's important. Now, put Jesus beside the next stanza because this
one, two, three, four stanzas actually is his response. And Jesus says, "Do you want me to speak
to you of love? Listen, my beloved daughter. My life is love. If I breathe, I love you.
If my heart beats, my heartbeat says love, love, I am mad with love for you." That's quite strong
language, isn't it? "If I move, I add love for you. With love, I inundate you. With love, I surround
you. With love, I caress you. With love, I dart through you. With love, I flash through you. With
love, I attract you. With love, I nourish you and sharp arrows I send into your heart." Okay.
Now, Louisa's response is the next number of stanzas. So, you put Louisa beside it.
Enough, all my Jesus, for now, I already feel faint with love. That song of songs, two, five,
song of songs, two, five, and five, eight, two, five, and five, eight. Sustain me in your arms and
close me in your heart. Now, the song of songs says, "Sustain me with apples because I'm fainting
with love." And apple, of course, is a symbol of love. Sustain me in your arms because Jesus
is love and close me in your heart. And from within your heart, let me, too, give vent to my love.
Otherwise, I will die of love. Now, when she says, "I will die of love," you're talking about the
ecstasy that love actually brings on. And when we meet together on the 29th, I'll explain to you
a wonderful insight that the Lord gave me about Louisa's privations because the assumption of
our blessed lady is that she went into this ecstasy of love and kept going. She never came back.
It's a fantastic thing when you just look at it. But I mean, that's only telling you what I'm
going to talk about, if you know what I mean. It's a wonderful thing. That's why Louisa says,
"I die of love." The soul wants to leave the body and go to love. With love I rave, with love I
burn, with love I must, I make feast, with love I language, with love I am consumed, love kills me
and makes me rise again more beautiful to new life. Now, the love killing her and rising again
are the deep privations and his return. Okay? My life escapes me and I feel only the life of Jesus,
my love. And in Jesus, my love I feel immersed and I love everyone. He wounds me with love,
he makes me ill with love, with love he embellishes me and he makes me ever more rich. Now,
some of the things that are said there, you mightn't remember but they're in volume three.
Okay? So, what you often find is that as you go forward you get revisions of things that have
been said before. So, Louisa continues in the next two stanzas, "I can say nothing more,
oh love, you alone understand me, you alone comprehend me, my silence tells you even more."
Silence you see is the most wonderful form of speech that our present generation knows very
little about. In your beautiful heart, one says more by keeping silent, now there you have it,
than by speaking. If I can illustrate it with the most obvious illustration on the planet,
it's this, that if somebody gives you a kiss on the lips they shut you up.
It's actually not possible to stay talking, am I right or am I right? So, love actually brings
two people to silence and the silence is union, the silence is union, it's the same thing spiritually.
Okay? So, one says more by keeping silent than by speaking and by loving one learns how to love,
which is correct isn't it? Love, love speak you alone because being love you know how to speak of
love. Okay, so Jesus responds in one, two, three, four, the next four stanzas, "Do you want to hear
love? All creation tells you love. If the stars twinkle they tell you love, if the sun rises it
gills you with love. If it shines with all of its light in its full day, it sends arrows of love to
your heart. If the sun sets it tells you it is Jesus that dies of love for you. We'd never think of
that, would we? No, no. In thunder and lightning I send you love and smacking kisses I give to your
heart. It is love that runs upon the wings of the wind and take the S off it. If the waters murmur,
I extend my arms to you. If the leaves move, I clasp you to my heart. If the flower gives you
its fragrance, I cheer you with love. It's not a most marvelous introduction to the rounds of creation.
All creation in mute language tells you in chorus, "From you alone do I want the life of love.
Love I want, love I desire, for love I beg from within your heart. I am only content
if you give me love." Now that is true of every human being that has ever lived. We were intended
to be conceived in love, to be nurtured in the womb in love, to be born in love, to be raised in love
and when you reach maturity to be ready to give love to the next generation. The whole thing was
meant to be a cycle of love and that when you reach the fullness of love that you go back to love
because God is love. It was meant to be that. It would be wonderful if it was wouldn't it?
So it makes me sad as well. So all creation in mute language, oh sorry yeah, tells you in chorus
it's from you alone that I want the life of love. Okay so I'm only content if you give me love. Now
Louisa responds. Louisa is great. She always gives some tit for tat. She never lets them have the
last word. I think that's completely feminine is it? One, two, three, four, five. So the last five
stanzas are Louisa. She gets the last word and the point is he lets her have it which I think is
amazing. My good and my all insatiable love. If you want love then give me love. You see we have
nothing. John 15 5. Without him we have nothing. We're not capable of anything. So we have to keep
on asking him to increase his love in us. If you want me happy then speak to me of love. If you want
me content then render me love. Love invests me. Love makes me fly and brings me to the throne of my
maker. Love shows me the uncreated wisdom which of course is Jesus himself and that comes from the
book of wisdom. Okay. The book of wisdom and it's chapter seven. Wonderful thing about wisdom there.
It leads me into the eternal love and there I set my throne because we're meant to be a little
flame of love going back to the fire of love. Life of love I will live in your heart. I will
love you for all. I will love you for all. I will love you for all and that's the thing that Louisa
teaches us isn't it? To love God for everybody. Jesus seal me completely with love inside of your
heart. Now to be sealed completely with love means all selfishness is dead gone over finished.
Empty my veins and instead of blood let love flow in them. Take away my breath and let me
breathe the air of love. Burn my bones and flesh and weave me completely completely with love.
May love transform me. May love conform me that is to the image of Christ.
May love teach me how to suffer with you. May love crucify me and make me all similar to you.
I think it's a fantastic thing. You just need to read it nice and slowly. Okay so March the 24th,
1911 the soul praised for the needs of the church. Continuing my usual state Louisa said
my beloved Jesus came and as I prayed to him for certain needs of the church and for a certain
person named who has given books on hell for publishing what's going to be here is really
extraordinary. So this person has whoever this bee is has written books on hell as given them
for publishing okay and he told me this is Jesus talking my daughter he did nothing but throw
himself even more into the mud in other words he doesn't know a brass firing about hell. So don't
believe everything that's written okay. Any mind of healthy reason will see immediately what a
curtain he is and how I have caused him to hallucinate not placing any true force of reason in what he
affirms. Isn't that something else? I don't want priests to bother reading it. I asked this is
fascinating to me and if they do they will render themselves too vile and they will descend from
their dignity as though wanting to pay attention to the nonsense of a child and therefore giving
him the field to do even more nonsense. So if you give him attention he'll get more.
Is that interesting? But by not bothering about him and not paying attention to him they will at least
give him the sorrow that no one pays attention to what it does and that no one appreciates him.
They will answer with the worthy works of their ministry. This is the most beautiful answer. Isn't
that something else? To him then it will happen that he will fall into the very trap he's preparing
for others. He'll be hung on his own petard. So you're not told what the purpose of writing these
books was but it looks as if somebody was writing something in a twisted way to get people involved
in the occult. So you tell them something Macabre and you kind of draw them in through fear and
fascination and all the rest of it. Jesus says don't touch. I think it's fascination his response there.
So March the 26th 1911 is about love again. This morning I was outside of myself. Louisa said
and I saw the celestial mother with the baby in her arms. The divine baby called me with this little
hand and I flew to put myself on my knees before the queen mother and Jesus told me my daughter. Now
I always love that image. He's an infant and he's talking to her my daughter. So all the language is
adult and yet she sees an infant. My daughter today I want you to speak with our mother. Notice the
hour. And Louisa said my celestial mother tell me is there anything in me that displeases Jesus
and she said dearest daughter of mine be tranquil. Jesus has spent 10 volumes trying to tell her to
be tranquil. For now I don't see anything that may displease Jesus. Now I want you to notice the
for now bit because human beings can change hour by hour. If may it never be you will run into
something that can displease him. I will let you know immediately. Look at that for mercy. Trust your
mother and do not fear. As the celestial queen assured me I felt new life being infused into me
and I added my most sweet mother what sad times we are living in. Tell me is it really true that
Jesus wants this retreat houses of priests. Now I think this is fascinating. Louisa gets a message
directly from Jesus and she has a doubt box in the back of her head and so soon she meets our
age. This is serious. And she said he surely does want it because the waves are rising too high
and these retreat houses will be the anchors the lamps the helm with which the church will be saved
from shipwreck is not interesting caused by the storm. Now the storm is all this invasion of communism
and Marxism and materialism and all the rest of it. In fact while it will appear that the storm has
submerged everything after the storm it will be seen that the anchors the lamps the helm that
is the most stable things in order to continue the life of the church are still there.
Now very often in the ancient world when storms and terrible things like war and everything happened
when it was all over and buildings were destroyed. You had the pillars of the building still standing.
We still have standing to this very day and that's why people wanted to put their names on pillars
because it would be everlasting you know. And that's what he's saying that these because they will be
according to his will they will remain and therefore the church can thrive again. Almost none of them
move while these are times for works. So he's saying they don't feel any sense of urgency. We
have the same thing today don't we? They don't seem to have the same the urgency of the times
and yes it is the time for works. The enemies are not resting while they remain in sluggishness.
Now that reminds me of the apostles asleep in Gethsemane when the salvation of the world was
being determined okay but so much the worst for them he said what you cannot get priests to take
on board is that privilege is one thing responsibility is quite another okay and then blessed mother
added my daughter try to make up for everything by means of love. Look at that love is the most
powerful thing in the universe. May you cherish one thing alone and that is to love.
Just one thought one word or one life love everything just love in your words your thoughts
your whole life. If you want to content and please Jesus love him and give him always the
occasion to speak of love. This is the only relief that cheers him love. Tell him to speak to you
of love and he will put you will put him in feast okay. I had something in my head when I was reading
that and it's gone now it'll come back. The only thing that will content him is love. We have got to
completely concentrate that love is the center and love is the only motive for anything that we do
and to love him in the divine will with his own love is the most powerful weapon you can use
to intercede for the church and the world okay. So Louisa said my tender Jesus did you hear what
our mother is saying as if he couldn't hear everything that I should ask you for love and to speak about
love and Jesus celebrating said such and so many things about the virtue the height that is the
summit when they say height you mean summit like the summit of sanctity okay whereas for us height
could be anything there could be three feet it could be a mountain you know. So the summit the
nobility of love that is not for the human language to be able to repeat it and therefore I stop okay.
So I want to give you one Corinthians two nine there that the eye cannot see and the ear cannot
hear and the heart cannot understand the great things that God has prepared for those who love him.
So May the 16th 1911 Jesus doesn't want to confound the enemies of the church and he cries over the
painful wounds that are in the body of the church. So Louisa said I was praying blessed Jesus to
confound the enemies of the church now she was asking him to do it and my beloved Jesus in
coming told me my daughter I could confound the enemies of the holy church but I don't want to.
Why? Because he loves them and he wants to save them and he would prefer that they would turn
around to truth and beauty and so on. If I did so who would purge my church? I want you to really
color that if you use color. Who would purge my church? You see it's the the people who are
disaffected with the church. It is the people who have gone into apostasy. It's the people who hate
the church. They are the ones who will fight against it and cause it pain and distress and even
persecution and even cause martyrdom but they're the ones who purify the church. I hate to say it
but they're God's little helpers. We like using that expression but we like using it in a different
context. The people who cause us trouble. The people who make our lives uncomfortable. The people
who think we're nothing and really challenge us are also God's little helpers in our lives
to produce virtue in us. So that's the parable of the tears and the wheat in Matthew 13. The members
of the church and especially those who occupy positions and heights of dignity. Now notice heights.
Now the height of dignity is the priest. It's the bishop and the cardinal and the pope.
And those who occupy positions and heights of dignity have their eyes dazzled and they blunder
a great deal. Now this is Jesus talking. If any the rest of us said it would be accused of all kinds
but he knows they blunder a great deal reaching the point of protecting the false
virtuous and oppressing and condemning the truly good ones. It's not interesting.
Now that would be because they're blinded by the philosophy of communism and Marxism
and their own materialism and so they're looking at other people with John just eyes.
Okay. This grieves me so much Jesus said to see those few true children of mine under the weight
of injustice. Those children from whom my church must rise again. Look at that. And to whom I am
giving such grace as to dispose them to do this. I see them placed with their backs to the wall.
Look at his language. I thought we were the only ones that use that kind of language
and bound to prevent their step. This grieves me so much that I feel I'm all fury for their
sake. Okay. Whereas if the leaders of the church did the right thing Jeremiah 29 11 would happen.
If you seek me with all your heart I would let you find me. Okay. So you put a CF there. In other
words go and compare this. So then Jesus continued my daughter. I am all sweetness, benign, clement
and merciful. So much so that because of my sweetness I enrapture hearts. Now Louisa keeps on saying
that. But I'm also strong and I'm able to crush and I'm able to reduce to ashes those who not only
oppress the good but reach the point of preventing the good which they want to do. Now that's Revelation
11 18. Revelation 11 18. I will destroy the destroyers of the earth. Very strong, isn't it?
You cry over the secular. Now the secular means they're not priests, they're laity and they're
the people in society. Okay. And I cry over the painful wounds that are in the body of my church.
Now he's talking about the priests and the bishops and the cardinals. These grieve me so
much as to surpass the wounds of the secular world. Because they come from the side from which I did
not expect it. And they induce me to make the worldly secular rail against them. Now it's it's
1911. I don't know the exact dates but they do you remember they took the papal states off the
church and the pope had to become a prisoner in the Vatican for ages. Now the Lord allowed what is
called the secular or the worldly people to punish the church. He actually allowed it. So May the 19th
1911 and we're having another one of these keys some day I'll talk about keys. This is the key of
confidence. Continue in my usual state my beloved Jesus made himself seen all afflicted and I was
around him all intent on sympathizing with him loving him embracing him and consoling him
with all the fullness of confidence. Now Louisa gets us to do that in the intercessions in the
hours of the passion. Okay. And my sweet Jesus told me my daughter you are my contentment.
I like it this way that the soul forgets about herself about her miseries and occupies herself
only with me. Now that means that we're not looking at our faults and our failings and our
struggles and our this and that deal that we're looking at him and we're loving him and you grow
much faster that way. And she occupies herself only with me with my afflictions and my bitterness
with my love and she remains around me with all confidence. Now the perfect example of that is
Saint Therese. And this confidence captures my heart Saint Therese said you will receive from God
exactly what you have the confidence to receive from him. This confidence captures my heart it
inundates me with so much joy that just as the soul forgets all of herself for me I forget everything
for her. Now Jesus says that to Louisa every now and then that look I have left all the stuff I'm
supposed to be doing in the world and I'm just going to give my attention to you. I forget everything
for her and I make her one single thing for me. That means the complete union. And I reached the
point of not only giving her but of letting her take whatever she wants. Now the saints who have
reached divine union have all said that that the Lord allows you to take from him whatever you want
because after all you're one with him. And that's like saying there is money in the family and
you're allowed to take what you want. On the other hand to the soul that does not forget everything
for me even her miseries and who if she wants to be around me does so with all respect with fear
and without confidence that captures my heart as though wanting to be with me with fearful restraint
and all circumspect to this one I give nothing. Is that interesting? Now notice the distance there
is between this person and the Lord because there's this fearful reaction. Somebody only told me within
the last week that the motivation that he had for all of his long life and it is a long life
was fear of hell. I said you're poor soul. Let's talk to you about the love of God.
Love is such a much much liberating thing than the fear of hell. You know. Now the fear of hell
this is a very old thing, very ancient. Now this person is old as well. You know what I mean? But I
couldn't believe that he hadn't shifted from that position. You know. That is, yeah. I give nothing
to that person he said and she, that's the soul, can take nothing because the key of confidence is
missing. The key of ease, you're supposed to be at ease with the Lord and feel that you're at home
with him. The key of simplicity is missing as the simplicity of a child putting their arms around
their father or mother and just loving them to the point where the father or mother would jump
over ditches of star about and bugs of buttermilk to get whatever the kid was looking for.
These are all necessary things in order for me to give. Now that is the key of confidence,
the key of ease, the key of simplicity and for her to be able to receive. And so she comes with
miseries and she goes with miseries. Isn't that sad? So she has her sort of religious experience
like going to Vassan Sunday and she comes out as bad as she went in. I think that's extremely sad.
Where St. Therese of Lesus said that every single time she received communion she was aware of
growing in holiness. Now I've never come across anybody else among the saints who said that every
time. Now I don't know if that puts you into a different box. It puts me into a different box.
Every time she received Holy Communion. Okay, so May the 24th, 1911. What God is by nature,
the soul is by grace. This is just totally fascinating. Okay, and I want to give you Sam 82, verse 6,
Sam 82, verse 6. I said you are God's, all of you sons of the most high.
Also want to give you, okay, Louisa said I was thinking of the incomprehensible greatness and
wisdom of God. Now she's literally quoting Romans 11, 33 to 36. The incomprehensible greatness and
wisdom of God, incomprehensible is that no matter how much you grow, no matter how much sanctity you
have, he's infinite and we're finite. Romans 11, 33 to 36. So I was thinking of the incomprehensible
greatness and wisdom of God, who in giving his goods to us does not decrease in anything. Just
because the sun gives us light, the sun doesn't become dark. It doesn't lose anything. On the
contrary, it seems that by giving he acquires the glory that the creature gives him for having
received the goods of the Lord. It's in giving that you receive. Okay, and those of us who teach
know that it is in teaching that you learn. Actually the teacher learns more than anybody in the class.
It's the amazing thing. And blessed Jesus in coming told me, my daughter, you too possess
this quality, not in your body, but in your soul, which was communicated to you by my goodness.
In fact, by trying to infuse good virtue, love, patience, sweetness into souls, you lose nothing
at all. In others, by trying to help others, you actually gain, you don't lose. On the contrary,
by infusing them in others, if you see that they take advantage of them, you enjoy a greater
satisfaction, which is true. And the teacher feels that as well, don't they? So that which you are
by grace in your soul, I am by nature. So that's Sam 8, 5. You've made us little less than a God
and crowned us with glory and honor, Sam 8, 5. And not only for the goods of the virtues, but all
possible goods, natural and spiritual of any kind. Someday it might dawn on you just what God is
offering to you. Most of us just can't take it on board. And we just take it just piece by piece,
but the whole treasure seems to dazzle us to the point where he can't actually take it in.
Unfortunately, June the 7th, 1911, we're back to priests again.
Going through most bitter days of privation of my adorable Jesus, I was praying him to
Dane to come. And he came just like a flash and he told me love that is hidden. Whoa, interesting. You see, if
you have love, you can't hide it. You must share it. Love demands an expression. You know that,
don't you? And love that is unrequited, that is there's no response back to you, is agony.
Okay, so he says love that is hidden. Whoa, then as I was praying him for the church and for pity on
many souls who become lost, because they want to wage war against the church. And for his ministers,
Jesus said, my daughter, do not afflict yourself. It is necessary that the enemies purge the church.
No, that was introduced a few passages back. And after they have purged her, the patients,
the virtues of the good will be light for the enemies. Look at the way God works.
In the Second World War, you had Mactimilian Colby being such a shining light in Auschwitz.
Do you remember the Germans? No, you don't. But there's one particular German that we have
remembered. And that is the comedant in the concentration camp, who at the end of his life,
absolutely turned and confessed his sins. Absolutely. And it can get it on the internet.
So the saint becomes light for others. So you had Edich Dine and her sister Rosa,
and they were able to give light to everybody else. She was able to say, let us sacrifice ourselves
for our people. So she's able to give everybody else a motive. The lives are going to be taken,
but it's much better to give it. Okay. And so you have these saints having an extraordinary
effect on others. So the deeper the crisis goes, the higher the sanctity of the Holy Ones goes,
and therefore the church is raised again, right out of the mud and put on the pedestal again.
That's the way the Lord works. So the patients and the virtues of the good will be light for the
enemies, that's Matthew 517. Matthew 517. And watch this, and both one and the other will be saved.
The persecutors get into heaven because the martyrs pray for them. We had a wonderful
example of a group of French monks in Morocco, who were martyred somewhere in the middle of the
20th century. I remember reading the letter of the abbot before they died, and it was absolutely
incredible. They all offered themselves to the Lord, and they were taken, and they were all we
had to, you know, but the extraordinary thing is that is the seed in Morocco, that Morocco will
come to Christ because they went there to testify to the Moroccan people about Christ, and they were
where they were mostly martyred. One, I think there was two members of the community that weren't
martyred, one of them because he was away doing business and came back and found all his community
dead. And the other one was so brave that he hid under a bed, and the persecutors couldn't
find him. They never thought of looking under a bed for a long time. But the glory is with the
ones who gave their lives. Oh good. So you can see therefore that the Lord works at both ends of
the line, and the people who seem to be heading straight for hell are the very ones who will be
saved. Now one of the things that Abbot said to the men who were going to behead them is we will
wait for you at the gates of heaven. Oh my God. You see, that's the triumph. That's total triumph.
We will wait for you at the gates of heaven. And Saint Stephen, the very first martyr,
said to Paul, the one responsible for his death, I will wait for you on the roads to Christ.
Oh, and did Stephen get his prayer answered? Paul was knocked off his horse. You know, fantastic
stuff. And sometimes it's the worst ones who will have the greatest conversions. It's just really
amazing. So I want to give you one Timothy two for God once everyone to be saved. Okay. And so
what appears at great evil, God can bring good out of evil. Okay. So Louisa said, but at least
don't permit that to watch this now. This is, to me, this is terribly important for the time we're
living in. Louisa said, at least don't permit that the faults of your ministers become known
to the secular. In other words, hide their sins. Isn't that the very reason why the church is being
persecuted now? Otherwise they will afflict the church even more. And Jesus said, my daughter,
do not pray me because I become indignant. This is not the way you should think. Okay. I want
this matter to come out. How is that? So I want to give you a Mark three, one to six. Mark three,
one to six. And I want to give you Matthew 10, 26. Why would Jesus want the matter to come out?
Because if it's kept hidden, it will fester and get worse and worse and worse, which is what has
happened in the last 50 to 60 years. Okay. And then you have an even worse scandal at the other
end of it. Okay. But if it's brought out in the beginning, it's like a wound that is lanced,
healed over, and you get armed with life. So he said, I want this matter to come out. I can take
no more. I can take no more. He said, the sacrileges are enormous. Now I've already explained to you
the origin of these sacrileges, because some of the men are just communist plants. Remember?
And they brought homosexuality into the priesthood. And of course, therefore the masses are sacrileges.
By covering them, that's hiding them, I would give them the field to commit even greater evils.
You will have patience in bearing my absence. He said, you'll do it as a heroine. I want to trust
you who are my daughter. While I occupy myself, we're preparing the scourges that the secular
are arranging for the priests. And he's doing this for the sake of releasing the priests from the
problems that they're in, and getting them to live a more healthy life. Now notice that
all of a sudden Jesus says something to Louisa, that Louisa would find very unacceptable if it was
given in a different context. He said, you will have patience in bearing my absence. Now no more
complaints. Okay? You will do it as a heroine. That means you can't say, oh, I'm dying. I'm dying.
You know, she usually does. Okay? So he gets his, as we would say, his spake in just at the moment
when there is something really serious talking here. So my summary of those lines is the truth
will out. But you remember Jesus said that what has been done in secret will be shouted from the
housetops. And I'm afraid the sins of the clergy around the world are shouted from the housetops
in the social media and the internet. Okay. The problem there is that the whole world knows then.
So June the 21st, 1911, again, we're talking about love and I have a VIP on this one.
There's no sanctity if the soul does not die in Jesus. Notice there's no sanctity. I want you to
ring the no. I was thinking of the celestial mother when she was holding my beloved Jesus
lifeless in her arms of what she did and how she occupied herself with Jesus and a light
accompanied by a voice in my interior. So the light is infused knowledge. The voice is an interior
location. Okay. Said my daughter love acted powerfully in my mother. You see, if she's in the divine
will, she's in love. Okay. Love consumed her completely in me, in my wounds, in my blood, in my very
death. And it made her die in my love. Now the church has always said that blessed mother is the
queen of martyrs. Okay. And my love consuming her love and the whole of my mother made her rise
again with new love. So there's the death and resurrection at work in us. That is all from my
love capital L for divine love. So her love made her die and my love, divine love, made her rise
again to a life that was all in me of a greater sanctity and fully divine. Now that's what the
Protestants don't want to even touch with a 40 mile rod that the love that operated in her was
fully divine because she was living at that level. She was living in the divine will. Therefore,
there is no sanctity if the soul does not die in me. Now this dying is dying to self. Okay. You die
to self and you die to all the you die to sin and you die to miseries and all of that. Okay.
And all of that dying stuff is in volumes one to four. Is that okay in case you need a revision?
There's no true life if she does not consume all of herself in my love. Now I want you to ring the
true. There's no true life. You haven't got the real thing. If you don't allow yourself to be
consumed completely in love. Now notice there's no option. You either stay the way you are with
self and the world and miseries and blah, blah, blah, or you let that all go and you take on
a divine love and take on divine will. So there's a huge challenge there for people to step up to
the mark. So June the 23rd, 1911, this is another VIP one on love. And you're going to be told that
there's no baggage allowance on the way to heaven. Love is the only thing you can take.
So won't give you the references to love because you have them all. As I was in my usual state,
blessed Jesus came for just a little and he told me, my daughter love is not subject to death. Why?
Notice it's a capital L. It's divine love. It's eternal. There's no power. There are no rights
over love. That's why people misunderstand that statement of Saint Augustine. Love God and do what
you like. Okay. And they think it is sort of be a good religionist and then you know be a selfish
as you want. There are no rights over love. Love is eternal. Now, but Saint Paul will tell you in
the references to love and that no law can hold love. Love is completely superior to law.
Love is eternal. And one who loves is eternal with me. If I can put it this way, the more you love,
the more substance of heaven you have inside of you. If you've reached the perfection of love,
then heaven exists inside of you with no dilution and you're ready to go. And if you die in that
condition, then you go straight up because all the dying and the purifying and everything is over.
Love fears nothing. As he Paul tells you all that in 1 Corinthians 13, love doubts about nothing
and love converts evils themselves into love. Okay. Now, how can you convert evil into love?
And that is Mactimilian Colby and people like him transforming the place of their punishment
into a divine place. Okay. And converting their enemies as well. So love converts evils themselves
into love. I myself am love. That's your 1 John 4, 7 to 17. I myself am love. And remember in the
early volumes, he said, I am grace as well. I am faith. I am hope. I am love. Okay. I love so
much. One who loves me in everything. That's your Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10 again. And one who does
everything out of love. Now, St. Therese got her PhD there. She did literally everything.
And it was St. Therese who said that if you pick up a pin off the floor with pure love for God,
it's worth all the projects on the planet. We're inclined to only put value if something is big
and huge and costs an immense amount of money. It's all interior. The value is all interior.
So I love so much. One who loves me in everything and who does everything out of love.
Woe to those who touch him. Oh, now I forgot this a number of times. There's a text in the Old
Testament that says, "Touch not my anointed." Okay. "Touch not my anointed and to my prophets
do no harm. I'm writing it down myself because I keep forgetting it." Hold on.
Do no. Let me write it down. So, "Touch not my anointed and to my prophets do no harm."
I'll find the reference and give it here. Okay. But I have remembered it and forgotten it too often,
so I'm writing the text down. And Jesus says, "Woe to those who touch them because someone living
this divine love is the most precious to Jesus." Okay. "I will make them be burned
by the fire of my terrible justice as the other side of Christ. His love is just. It's not just
merciful." Okay. So if somebody would touch his treasures, he's not going to take that.
Isn't that interesting? So love is just and justice is loving. So July 2nd, 1911, this is another VIP
one on love. Wherever there is love, there is life. But we used to sing that in Latin.
"Ubi carry tas et amor deus imbi es." Do you remember? "Ubi carry tas et amor deus imbi es." It was one of the very
favorite tunes you would sing at benediction or at a holy hour where there is love and charity.
There is God. Okay. And that's what they're going to say here as well because God is love.
"Continue in my usual state. Blessed Jesus came for just a little and he told me. My daughter,
wherever love is, there is life." Now notice life is with the capital L. That means there is God.
And not human life, but divine life. So there is God. So you can interspers God and life there.
"Therefore, all the works, also good ones which are not done out of love, are light painted,
fire. A painted fire doesn't keep you warm in the winter, which gives no heat or like painted
water which won't do anything for your thirst. It quenches no one's thirst and does not purify.
Oh, how many painted or dead works are done, also by persons consecrated to me."
That's sad. In fact, love alone is that which contains life. No other thing contains as much
power to give life to everybody or rather without love, everything's dead. So God is love. God is
life. If love is there, life is there. If love is not there, the thing is dead. Okay.
Have you ever received a present from someone and you knew that they had to sort of give it to you?
There's no love in it. Yeah, it's awful. And you're not complimented. You don't even want to open the
darn thing. You know the content is love. And so a person could give you something that's actually
quite expensive, but they're doing it for themselves. Do you know what I mean? It's for their own image
or whatever it is. And a child will come along and pull your favorite flower and not even pull it
properly and come in and say, Daddy, I love you and you couldn't pay for it because that's coming
straight from the heart. And they're giving you what you know is precious. Like it was me now
that they bring in a rose. Okay. They'd know that I would prize that more than anything else. And
that's what you're looking at is that the child went to find a sign to put on their little words.
And that's worth everything. As you know, your parents, you know. But something that's not
given with love has no value at all. I remember having to try and help to heal a person whose
parents kept on giving her material things but never gave her love. She was a wreck when I met her,
an absolute wreck and had no motivation to live or anything. She came to me in a suicidal bid.
And I kept her for nine months, the gestation period. And then sent her out when she had been
born again. Okay. So September the 6th, 1911. One who pays attention to herself grows thin and
emaciated. Now actually the image he's going to give you here is anorexia nervosa. Okay. The one
who's always looking in the mirror and I'm too fat. So they won't eat. And I'm still too fat and
they're getting thinner by the day and then they become seriously ill. Now he's saying that for us
to look at ourselves all the time and to keep examining ourselves and our miseries and everything
that you've got spiritual anorexia nervosa. Because if I give you anorexia nervosa, you know what he's
actually saying. So self-absorption is the absolute worst disease in spiritual life. I'm not talking
about sin. I'm talking about a disease. It continues almost the same way, Louisa says, that is with
most bitter privation and with silence, that means Jesus is chastising. At most he only makes
himself seen and is it's usually about the usual things and therefore I don't write them. The usual
things of course are all the chastisements and what's going on in the world. Now when you get to the
higher volumes Louisa won't get away with that. She has to write everything. I mean look at some of
these messages here are only a few lines. When you get up over volume 20 you can have three or four
fool's cap pages as one message. The Louisa up there is completely changed. Okay. So
I remember that when I admit some lament about my state, he tells me my daughter have patience,
do this as a stalwart, as a heroine. He's trying to tell her now twice he's told her recently.
Courage, let me chastise for now and then I'll come as before. Now the next paragraph I have a
heading looking for trouble. I also remember that as I was concerned about my state and he doesn't
want her concerned about her state but she keeps coming back to it. He told me my daughter, one who
wants to pay attention to difficulties and doubts to herself is like those fussy persons who feel
disgust for everything and instead of thinking about nourishing themselves they think of the
rubbish even if it's not there and therefore they grow thin and emaciated and they die.
Anorexia nervosa is interesting but there are people suffering from spiritual anorexia nervosa.
For example they want to go back for the tenth time to confess a sin that they committed 20 years
ago. At what point did they go to accept forgiveness and just put it behind you?
And then she says some little things that don't remember well. So in the next section we're going
to be dealing with apostasy in Italy and France because you know the enlightenment began in France
and therefore France is really responsible for all this communism that's come to us.
People don't think of that. They say communist and they say Russia but Russia wasn't the source of it.
France brought in the secularism and the materialism and the atheism to us when they
absolutely rejected the church in the so-called French Revolution.
This morning Louisa said I was outside of myself and I found baby Jesus in my arms crying so very
strongly because he heard that they wanted to cast him away from Italy. This is apostasy.
See Louisa gets it in very simple images. We made our way towards France and they didn't want to
receive him. You see the apostasy in France. Now he's going to tell her that both France and Italy
will be severely punished in the two world wars and you know that yourself if you know the history
of the world wars. And my always lovable Jesus crying said everyone drives me away nobody wants me
and I forced by themselves will scourge them. Okay now I have only added two words including
Ireland. We're at the stage where we've also thrown them out. By we you mean the nation. You're
not talking about individuals. In the meantime I saw roads full of rocks and fire with great damage
the cities. In other words she's seeing world war one. Okay. Do you see letters retreat my daughter
letters retreat he said. And so we retreated into my bed and he disappeared. Then after a few days
as I was praying him to placate himself because of the many scourges that one hears about he told
me my daughter they treat me like a dog and I make them kill one another like dogs. Isn't that crazy?
In other words if the great commandment is given to you like this you to love God and love your
neighbor. Now after the fall of Adam when they broke the covenant with God the very next thing
you hear is murder. You break the covenant with God in chapter three of Genesis you have your
first murder in chapter four. We are not capable of being civil to each other unless there's love
of God in us. That's why Jesus put those two commandments as the two commandments on which
the entire scriptures hinge that you must love God and your neighbor. Okay. And so
what he says here is if they treat God like a dog obviously he's not thinking of dogs that are
domesticated and made like pets at home. He's not talking about that at all he's talking about dogs
being treated as animals that are not tamed okay and they're just treated badly and he said they
will treat one another the same way as well. I find that very amazing. So Louisa said it was
terrible heartbreak. So let's come to October the 6th and we'll do this one and then stop.
So October the 6th we're told that we can do everything with Jesus that's Philippians 4, 13.
Okay. Louisa says I was thinking to myself how is it possible that blessed Jesus in order to
chastise people has to deprive me of his loveable presence. Now she's been that's been answered
endlessly. I presume you don't need an explanation. I would like to see whether he does this to other
souls to make themselves seen. I believe that these are excuses she says or that it's something
in me which prevents him from coming. He's told her endlessly that's not so. And Jesus just barely
making himself seen my daughter it really is true that I do not come because of the chastisement.
Now he's being very patient with her. In other words if you've got to be told 10 times something
that's perfectly obvious you know the person is being rather patient with you. And suppose if you
would like if I go to somebody else this says nothing. Everything is in the state that the souls
have reached through my grace. Okay. In other words if you're a victim soul you're a victim soul
whether I'm present or absent. Let's put it this way if you're married you're married whether the
spouses with you at this moment are not. And even if you're in two different countries at a particular
point because somebody's on holidays or on retreat you're still married okay because that's your state
and Louisa has to try and take this on board like whether she has sufferings or not she's still
in the state of a victim soul. So for example he said if I went to the soul of a beginner
or has not reached the possession of me did not reach union with God possession of him is union
with God right union with God over that union with God. And so and they've not reached union
with God as if I were all her own she would do little or nothing to me. Naturally they're only
beginners so they don't even really know him. She'd not have that daring that confidence to discern
me and to bind me as she pleases because these are all timid before me and with reason because
they haven't really entered properly into the relationship because they've not entered into me
as the owners so as to be able to dispose as they wish. On the other hand when the soul has reached
the point of possessing me that's union with God she is daring and she is confident she knows all
the divine secrets look at that all the divine secrets and with reason she can say to me if you
are mine I want to do what I want because that's what's saying Augustine said love God and do what
you like. And this is why I hide to be able to act because they would suffer greatly in uniting with
me to chastise so they would prevent me from doing it. Here my daughter is the necessity that I do
not manifest myself to you otherwise I want to hear it from you yourself. What would you do to me?
How much would you not be opposed? And Louise said certainly Lord I would have to stick to all that
you yourself have taught me in other words I have to stick with my job as a victim soul. I have to
love the creatures as your images that's Romans 8 19 and as yourself you must love your neighbor
as yourself okay. Now if I could see you as before you would never be able to if I could see you as
before you would never be able to permit the war initially but you hide and I remain as nothing
pure nothing. Now my heading over this little paragraph is nothingness with you I can do everything
without you I can do nothing. Now you know your two references don't you John 15 5 without me you
can do nothing and then Philippians 4 13 you can do all things in Christ. And Jesus said you see
you see it yourself so if I came to you the war would be reduced to a game while my will is for
it to bring sad and grave consequences. Now look at that clearly that God permits war because there
are things that will happen through war that won't happen any other way. Therefore I repeat to you
my refrain courage be at peace be faithful to me don't act like a child who forces over everything
it's not interesting. You've never said to espouse we just stop fussing but be like a heroine he says
that means someone who bravely takes everything. I do not really leave you it's not possible because
the Blessed Trinity indwells our souls and if the divine will left us we would disintegrate.
So I don't really leave you as one Corinthians 3 16. No you not that you are the temple of the
living God and the spirit of God dwells in you. But I will remain hidden in your heart now in all
the volumes that will come after this you'll hear her saying he came out from within my heart he came
out from within my heart and you will continue to live in my will and if we don't do it so the
people will reach such excess okay as to strike terror and fright. Now notice the way because Louise
is living in the divine will and somehow she has to conform somehow to the divine will he said if
we don't do this the people will reach such an excess that will be utterly frightful. Now when you
consider World War I the war to end all wars and he says that it could have been infinitely worse than
that. Makes you think I'm going to stop there.